so we've just finished our April council
meeting there were five hundred and
three pages of agenda including public
excluded we kicked off the meeting with
a moment's silence floor a former
colleague a llama grovia passed away in
the weekend we were then went into the
earthquake recovery program we spent 23
million over 41 million thats budgeted
for that surveillance camera upgrade and
kaiapoi 57 winter into various reports
clean water discussion document we
approved 13,000 to the library and lee
wastewater treatment plant a few inside
water supply scheme ashley rural water
supply review we review the policy on
flying drones and our packs
of particular interest with our customer
service and satisfaction survey which
says cheered us up from seventy-six
percent three years ago to eighty-five
percent which is a fantastic result for
the council but across the organization
we discussed NZXT premises everybody
will know we've got to Anzac Day coming
up and counselors will attend various
services across the district in
committee there were three particular
items of interest and because it will in
committee I'm not going to go into
detail but nevertheless we approve the
expenditure of neon five million dollars
on those and committee items which will
come out of committee and you course
[Music]
you